ja wir kommen zu einer neuen serie von
4cast diesmal habe ich hier den tätern
als gast oder peter ist theologe und
zwar systematischer theologe der unter
peter kennt sich sehr gut mit der sünde
aus wir geben zusammen ein seminar an
diesem semester über die sünde das böse
aus philosophisch theologische
perspektive peter wir hatten hier schon
einige sendungen über das böse aus
überwiegend philosophischer perspektive
aber auch aus psychologischer
perspektive
jetzt würde mich mal interessieren was
ist eigentlich die theologie zur sünde
sagen kann und wie sich die sünde vom
bösen erscheint hast du da eine idee
tja die erste frage ist natürlich sehr
weitreichend technologie ist eine
jahrhundertealte bald und wissenschaft
die natürlich unheimlich viel für die
sünde gesagt haben das könnte man kaum
so zusammenfassen
die zweite frage was das sind die sünde
und das böse berühren lässt ist sehr
schwer zu machen worden
denn die sünde ist ja ein genuin
religiöser begriff man braucht
eigentlich so was wie einen religiösen
kontext um zu verstehen was mit sünde
gemeint ist während das böse ein ganz
abstrakter begriff ist aus der
philosophie der mann aber auch aus der
kultur kennt aus der kunst kennt aber es
gibt definitiv eine gewisse
verwandtschaft denn diese berührung
zwischen beiden die haben wir im seminar
behandelt jetzt ist es ja so dass das
böse häufig nur betrachtet wird aus der
perspektive des handelnden also diese
handlungen böse willens gesinnungen böse
maximen
man würde sehr selten sagen das ist ein
böser mensch das gibt es zwar diese
redeweise hält sich da ja so ein
bisschen zurück wie ist es mit der sünde
geht die sünde der begriff der sünde
darin auf das man nur ein mensch
untersucht und seien willen und seine
handlungen oder kommt da nicht noch mehr
dazu eine neue dimensionen des wenn wir
gegenüber den bösen auf der begriffs
eben sind sich die sünder das böse an
den punkt glaube ich sehr ähnlich denn
auch bei der sünder haben wir das
problem dass wir von ihr abstrakt werden
können diese endeten die gibt es
unabhängig von sünden als tat oder
sünden sündigen menschen es gibt aber
auch den sinn der also die sünde
personifiziert in einer person als würde
sie an ihm kleben und es gibt taten die
man als sünde bezeichnet man kann eine
sünde tun nicht nur die sünde tun das
ist ja eine begriffs logisches problem
was man mit dem bösen ganz genauso und
abstrahiert man das böse oder gibt es
nur böse böse handlungen böse maxime
kann sagen würde jetzt scheint mir oder
uns in dem seminar wenn es um die sünde
die man erneut dimension noch mit dem
spiel gekommen zu sein jetzt mit bezug
auf gott auf und das verhältnis zu gott
worin würde jetzt genau im verhältnis zu
gott ist liebe spielt kann man das so
ganz allgemein mal definieren als
theologe zunächst muss man glaube ich
festhalten dass immer ein problem
darstellt
sünde oft genug mit einer fragwürdigen
problematischen handlung in verbindung
bringt man spricht immer von der
ethischen dimension oder gar von dem
missbrauch das sind begriffe die
verkehrssünde die schwarzwälder
kirschtorte an den kalorien sind und da
wurde immer schon viel daran gearbeitet
und gezerrt ob das überhaupt eine
angemessene weise dem begriff zu
verwenden die meisten in der theologie
versuchen seit jahrhunderten zu betonen
diese tat sünden seien gar nicht das was
sie sind da eigentlich ausmacht im haus
sagt dass sie ihren kirkegaard ist sehr
gut angenommen da ist ja definitiv nicht
der einzige es viele ansätze in der
theologie gehen sogar dahin zu sagen
eigentlich verbietet sich sogar der
plural der sünden es sei viel sinnvoller
vom von der sünde als einen grund
zustand ein urzustand zu sprechen der
das wesen des menschen insgesamt zu
fassen versucht das wesen des menschen
als ein eines profan wesens wie eine
beschmutzung wie eine tiefe
wertlosigkeit oder oder oder entfremdung
vom eigentlich heiligen göttlichen
vollkommene als sei die sünde ein
begriff für eine intuition für ein
gefühl des menschen dass in dieser welt
in diesem leben in seiner existenz etwas
nicht stimmt dass er sich entfremdet
oder defizitär fügt gegenüber etwas ganz
anderes was er als das göttliche als das
heilige verehrt an diesem punkt wird es
richtig spannend was den sünden begriff
betrifft und an dem punkt ist man
natürlich dann auch weit weg von
effektiv
kalorien sünde an einem punkt wird
allerdings da auch noch mal
interessanter man könnte natürlich die
einzelne tat sünde als ein ableger als
eine folgeerscheinung des grund problems
der sünde beschreiben weil der mensch
eben ein gefallenes wesen traditionell
gesprochen einen von gott entfremdetes
wesen ist der sündenfall ist es ihm
immer nur um sich selbst zu tun arbeitet
der mensch immer nur egoistisch und die
einkreist und die eigene lebens
problematik kommt auch aus dieser
begrenzung aus diesem unvermögen ich
heraus und all diese daten die wir als
alltags sind bezeichnen während dann
entsprechend folgeerscheinungen und
lassen sich zurückführen auf die
eigentliche wurzel seit seiner science
eine letzte frage peter wir hatten heute
wie seminar das dämonische gesprochen
von paul c die kannst du ganz kurzen auf
unseren zuschauern erklären was es mit
dem dämonischen auf sich hat das
dämonische ist ein begriff der in der
moderne besonders interessant wurde
könnte fast sagen neu entdeckt wurden im
zuge des besonders der
historisch-kritischen forschung
man fing an sich in den alten
überlieferungen alten texten
dokumenten und natürlich besonders in
der bibel für textstellen und text
tradition zu interessieren die man sonst
eigentlich gerne überlesen hat die nicht
zum kerngeschäft des gesetzes des
evangeliums gehören sondern eher dunkel
geblieben sind und fängt an zu verstehen
dass die ganz elementar für die
religions- geschichtliche entwicklung
des judentums des christentums waren wo
gott eben nicht der erhabene im heutigen
sinne monotheistische ganz transzendente
gott ist sondern wo er erscheint als ein
ganz dunkles und andere provence riesen
verbunden mit wettererscheinung voller
zorn voller eifersucht wo es zwischen
weesen gibt dämonen krankheiten engel
wesen also wo es richtig turbulent
zugehen könnte und sagen in der bildwelt
dies eben nicht mehr abzustoßen als
gemüse was das sozusagen der reinen
religion angewachsen ist sondern das als
elementare schiffe zu verstehen als
ausdrucksform eines tiefen einer tiefen
intuition des menschen für die
andersartigkeit für die fremdheit gottes
und da ist der begriff des dämonischen
gewählt worden goethe spielt natürlich
eine große rolle in dieser
begriffsgeschichte und man brachte dann
das dämonische eben mit der religiösen
intuition mit dem ring
die wesen apriori ist dann eine moderne
genannt wurde dass menschen zusammen und
versucht es dann genauer zu verstehen
paul tillich bedeutend theologen des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts hat der begriff
dein herz besonders intensiv erarbeitet
und versuchte mit ihm den eigentümlichen
zustand zu beschreiben dass das heilige
das sakrale in der welt immer in der
gefahr steht ins gegenteil zu kippen und
das gegenteil seiner selbst zu werden
ein beispiel wäre ein als heilig
verehrte mensch ein priester der
natürlich auf das heilige auf der sakral
auf das göttliche verweist in seinem amt
in seiner funktion
es steht aber immer die gefahr dass er
das missbraucht oder dass er falsch
verstanden wird und dass das heilige was
eigentlich nur an ihm hängt oder auf das
er verweist ihn selbst erblicken das
menschliche wird zum heiligen gemacht
dass er gerade wird das eigentlich
weltliche wird zum sakralen dass es eine
tiefe gefahren die in allen religionen
steckt und dann wegen die religion immer
gearbeitet haben in dem versuch
dogmatisch den gottesbegriff klarer zu
fassen im versuch sich von dem was man
götzendienst oder aberglauben and zu
lösen
das sind alles
arbeitsstellen könnte man fast sagen wo
man versucht das heilige vom dämonischen
zu trennen
natürlich fehlt nun den kniff das
dämonische nicht als einen fehler einem
system zu entlarven sondern ist als eine
schöpferische qualität auszuzeichnen als
etwas als eine eigene der religion und
auch dem heiligen selbst in einem
produktiven schöpferischen ja ja ja das
ist eine sehr spannende thematik
wir haben in der heutigen sitzung
gezeigt dass es mit dem bösen allein
nicht getan ist und das wird durchaus
auch eine andere dimension betrachten
müssen man als bescheiden könnte
vielen dank nochmal peter für das
interview und ist zur nächsten sendung
vom film cast